Matthew is in Austin Texas hey Matthew
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks so much for taking my call sure
it's not gonna help
well I currently basically started your
debt snowball plan or more or less the
one you always say that it's never
really your idea but that seems more
like logic than anything else but anyhow
we started about a year ago we're
currently in about two hundred thirty
thousand dollars worth of debt with
student loans and credit cards and
whatnot what I'm trying to figure out
right now we have two children and we're
wondering whether or not this would be a
good time to expand on our family two
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
debt does that include your mortgage
that has nine clear our mortgage no
who's the doctor that would be me doctor
of physical therapy your PT and you
spent 200 grand to be a PT I did and
this was before I got really gung-ho
into looking at the finances because up
until then I was trying to look for what
the best career choice and it's always
something I wanted to do but I could
honestly never make it happen and the
job I was working beforehand we couldn't
really increase income and so so what do
you mean what's your household income
combined it's about 175 okay well that's
good news right and so um I don't think
having a how much of that income is you
so right now I'm working both a
full-time and PRN or weekend side gig to
just try to bring as much income as
possible good
so my my combined income with those two
is roughly about eighty eighty-five and
so she's making eighty eighty-five right
about yes sir okay all right and well
basically what amounts to is is what
this is going to do is slow down by the
time that she takes off you're right at
snoball progress but because at 175
versus 250 that you know that shovel to
hole ratio
it's doable I mean you're gonna clear
that up in about three years plus or
minus another time when we predicted
right
yeah plus or minus maternity leave right
and so all right is she going you do not
have the option of her quitting and
coming home not quitting no sir you
don't have that option not until this
stuff's cleaned up now we're trying to
actually get a idea of what her
maternity leave policy is and know I
mean how about the main part we're
waiting permanently permanently no now
that's what I mean she's not gonna be a
full-time mom with three kids with
$250,000 just didn't wound that you have
another shot with an engineering firm
and so it's kind of one of those rare so
the bottom line is you're going to lose
you know you're gonna lose two months of
pay out of the next 36 months if you
have a baby right that's what I'm
anticipating yeah you know and so that's
okay yeah I don't have babies based on
money but I just want to use common
sense and wisdom and looking at this and
so you know right are you on some kind
of an extreme edge here and really well
they mean the edge or not extreme edge
but not extreme edge but I mean we're in
our 30s our mid 30s and 34 she's 33 our
goal you know if we were contemplating
it would then to start trying yeah about
your so but she's you know concerned
about her biological clock so that's not
what I'm talking about what I talked
about about it you have a baby when
you're ready to have a baby that's my
point
but the point is is that really two
months of income of her income over 36
months doesn't really move the needle
that much so it doesn't keep you from
having a child but it does make her go
back to work after the child is
delivered for sure because you've got to
finish cleaning the mess up